I made seven little burros huge stars
and I'm ready to prove to the world that
I can do it all over again Dance Moms is
back with a brand new cast and fans are
happier than ever but some have noticed
that the new dancers and the original
crew have a lot in common
keep watching to find out which dancer
is totally taking a page out of Jojo si
waz buck Sara the new page Dance Moms
fans couldn't help but think that Sara
georgiana
seemed a little bit familiar at first
many of us believed her to be the new
Chloe but it didn't take us long to
realize that she's the new Paige Paige
island was often seen as the underdog I
just think that you underestimate Paige
she loved performing gymnastic numbers
and was often compared to Chloe and the
same can be said about Sarah
Dance Moms fans are divided when it
comes to this topic but we personally
think that Paige and Sarah are a lot
more alike than Chloe and Sarah sure
Sarah might look a lot like Chloe but
she has the same sweet and likable
quality to her that Paige was always
known for sure she's not the best dancer
on the team but it's your job to make
the corrections but she's an underdog
you can't help but root for her besides
there's another dancer who's got Chloe's
name written all over her Savannah the
new Chloe Savannah and Chloe are a lot
alike
they're both super amazing dancers who
often find themselves in second place
you're all winner would have been Maddie
Savannah is known for being a very chill
and friendly person she's a great friend
who supports those around her
instead of getting super jealous so she
instantly reminded us of Chloe on top of
that Savannah is often compared to Paige
and since Chloe and Paige were best
friends it makes sense that Savannah and
Sarah would get compared to each other
every once in a while it's also obvious
that Savannah is one of the best dancers
on the team it was good
set the tone of the level of the dance
however there seems to be a rivalry
going on between her and another student
if this on-screen rivalry goes on to
remind us of Chloe and Maddie's then
we'll know for sure that Savannah is the
new Chloe keep watching to find out who
the new Maddie is Presley the new
Mackenzie Mackenzie Ziegler was a Dance
Moms fan favorite for more reasons than
one not only was she adorable and sweet
but Kenzie was also talented beyond
belief
I made Abby cry because I don't like
they act really good she was the
youngest dancer on the team but always
managed to bring something new to the
table are we the only ones who think
that Mackenzie and Presley are a lot
alike we have highly doubt it Presley
has an awesome personality which is why
many viewers find themselves gravitating
towards her I think that is cute she's
super dynamic on stage and it's fun to
watch whether she's your favorite or not
isn't important because you'll still
find yourself rooting for her whenever
she's onstage Giannina the new Jojo it's
no secret that Jojo C hua has an
over-the-top personality but it's her
larger-than-life attitude that has
turned her into such a famous celebrity
Jojo is also known for her huge Bo
collection and you hardly ever see her
without a bow on her head
Jojo well it looks like Giannina is
trying to cash in on that trend too but
this time she's using cat ears to mark
her territory a lot of fans are a little
peeved over the fact that Jia Nina and
her mother seemed to be chasing Fame
instead of actually wanting to be a part
of the ALDC
since Giannina is already booking
professional jobs it seems a little
strange that she would wind up on Dance
Moms on Billboard's billboards either
way it's clear that Giannina is trying
to emulate Jojo with the bobo style what
do you guys think Hanna
the new Nia Nia Frazier is by far one of
the nicest girls to have ever danced for
the ALDC she loved to perform
contemporary numbers and was often
criticized for lacking technique yeah
your turn and well this same can be said
about Hanna Collin the young dancer
started honing her craft when she was
just 18 months old
much like Nia
Hannah loves performing contemporary
dances and also needs to work on
improving her technique you do not apply
Corrections quick enough for me
fans have even noticed that Hannah is
beginning to come off as an underdog if
Hannah isn't able to improve her
technique she's going to wind up in the
same position as Nia what do you guys
think is Hannah the new Nia Brady and
the new Kalani Dance Moms fans couldn't
wait to see Brady Ferrar in action Brady
is the first boy to ever become a
permanent member of the ALDC elite team
he's 14 years old and one of the oldest
dancers in The Dance Moms season 8 so
fans couldn't help but to compare him to
Kalani fans have taken to Reddit to
state that Brady and Kalani are totally
twinning not only is Brady one of the
best dancers on the show but he doesn't
need to over practice in order to land
the lead Brady is leave the group dance
it's happening again Brady is totally
drawing inspiration from Kalani who was
often deemed as one of the best dancers
on Dance Moms
Kalani quickly became one of Abby Lee
Miller's favorite dancers thanks to her
overall look and incredible flexibility
I think the whole package right and well
the same can be said about Brady and now
the moment you've all been waiting for
let's find out who the new star of the
show is Liliana the new Maddie it's no
secret that Maddie Ziegler was Abby Lee
Miller's favorite student for years the
original cast watched as their dance
teacher praised Maddie and pleased her
at the top of the pyramid Maddie Lilly K
first appeared on Dance Moms in season
six as part of the ALDC mini team
so now Lily's a permanent member of the
ALDC fans are convinced that Lily it's
the new Maddie for more reasons than one
the first one being that lily has
already been at the top of the pyramid
featured role in a group for the very
first time
and the second one being that Abbi seems
to be setting up a rivalry between lily
and savanah who resemble Maddie and
Chloe respectively so do you guys think
that the new Dance Moms cast is trying
too hard to be like the original cast
let us know in the comments section and
while you're at it tell us who your new
favorite dancer is and why and that's a
wrap
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up or to subscribe to the things
thanks for watching we'll see you next
time
[Music]